Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Willkommen im Zentrum operative Kommunikation der Mieterebene.
Ich dachte, das wäre eine geheime Verschlusssache.
Ja, liebes Informationsumfeld, ihr seid wieder eingeladen zur Wissenserschließung aus offenen Quellen hier bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik. Die äh einhundert
elfte Ausgabe eins eins denkt euch dabei was ihr wollt? Ja Linus, oder? Bist du noch da?
Ja, ich bin noch da, ich bin noch da.
Super. Wir müssen halt hier mal wieder alles gepetzt.
Alles alle Witze weggenommen aus dem nächsten Thema.
Geil, oder? Nee, aber ehrlich gesagt, da ist schon noch eine Menge zu holen, deswegen dachte ich, das muss man einfach mal ausschlachten. So bin ich. Einfach.
Wir hatten das, was mich, ich ich frage mich, ob wir das Thema nicht hatten. Also ich meine das da hatten wir ja alles schon drüber gesprochen.
Auch so. Wollen wir das mal äh einleiten das Thema? Ich meine so richtig.
Ja, ich wollte noch, ja, ich hätte jetzt kurz noch eine Anekdote von meiner Oma erzählt, aber das ist, lass fangen wir lieber mit dem Thema an.
Nee. Das ist irgendwie nee.
Also meine Oma war nicht bei der Bundeswehr. Notfalls jetzt hier.
So ein Zufall. Auch nicht.
Noch nie Spur jetzt oder was? Das mit der Sendung?
Das hieß damals halt auch noch nicht Bundeswehr. Aber da war sie trotzdem auch nicht. Also große Meldung letzte Woche, Bundeswehr nutzt soziale Medien zur Aufklärung.
Von Stimmungslagen,
Es war dann auf Spiegel Online hieß es da glaube ich Bundeswehr, will will Facebook äh nutzen oder oder zur Spionage nutzen. Und ähm.
Ich glaube, der Ablauf war wahrscheinlich so, dass es eine kurze Meldung dazu gab und dann sich daraufhin ergab eine äh ähm,
eine kleine Anfrage der äh Linken hier wieder in Form von Andre Hunko, der macht ja nichts anderes der Mann, das nimmt seine Arbeit ernst, stellt äh kleine Anfragen und hat sich diesmal an das äh Innenministerium gewendet,
weil er wissen wollte, wie denn die Bundeswehr da gedenkt äh Facebook äh zu für seine militärischen Zwecke,
äh zu nutzen oder andere ähm soziale Netzwerke zu nutzen,
und vor allem mit Hilfe von welcher Software, da hätte man natürlich dann so eine Antwort wie äh Ex-Keescore oder so was äh,
als als Oberbingo haben können, aber es stellt sich raus, äh die Bundeswehr möchte äh,
das Analysetool und die Social Media Monitoring Software Brandwatch nutzen.
Das äh zeigt also es scheint also eher irgendwie sowas zu sein, dass du deine Marke,
ne, dass du guckst, was was wird über deine Marke gesagt, also es scheint irgendwie so ein Social Media Berater ich weiß ja nicht, gibt's für Social Media Berater schon jetzt auch eigene Software wahrscheinlich dann, ne, Brandwatch.
Klar. Also ich meine die halt natürlich, also ich meine solche Tools sind nun wirklich nichts Besonderes, inwiefern jetzt diese Software vielleicht äh innerhalb dieser äh des Genres nochmal besonders ist, vermag ich nicht zu beurteilen. Das äh kann sein, kann nicht sein.
Aber natürlich gibt's äh allerlei Tools, mit denen ähm quasi so die Wirkung von Social Media Kampagnen gemessen werden kann, eben,
unter anderem eben diese Auswertung. Teilweise machen das ja auch äh Systeme wie Twitter auch schon selbst. Das
quasi systemseitig eben genau ähnliche Daten ähm den User also ausgewählten Usern bereitstellen. Ja unter anderem ja zum Beispiel auch den
wie heißt das nochmal so schön, diese Proof-User, die mit dem blauen Häkchen ähm ja die sehen da sozusagen auch so Response und was ist jetzt von dir da am meisten retweetet worden und Pipapo? Ist äh so ein bisschen so ein Promifeature
und äh kein Zweifel,
es gibt da sicherlich noch besondere Zugänge für äh Firmen, die sich da jetzt nochmal besonders einkaufen oder die sonst so wie irgendeinen Analytics Climbing machen.
Also die mit dem blauen Häkchen, das sind so die die Lufthansa Senatoren des, des Twitters, ne. Also die können.
So.
Die haben extra, die haben, die haben Privilegien.
Na ja, es geht so. Also ich habe auch so ein Häkchen, das ist so richtig, richtig durchatmend kann man dann auch noch nicht. Es bleibt trotzdem irgendwie der gleiche Scheißdienst.
Das gehört auch zum Lufthansa Senator sein. Du musst dich die ganze Zeit beklagen und beschweren und alles, was dir gegeben wird, es ist nicht genug und du willst am Ende doch nur ein Upgrade in die First Clo.
Das kann ich ganz gut. Vielleicht schaffe ich es mal vom blauen Häkchen auf ein goldenes Häkchen. Das goldene Häkchen. Ja, das hätte ich gerne.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall die die das das Z-Opcom BW möchte gerne, dass Info u bei Auslandseinsätzen aufklären und nutzt dafür natürlich das Forschungsprojekt. Klar. Soweit klar. Übrigens.
Ich frage mich immer, ob die in der in der in der Bundeswehr sich auch tatsächlich den ganzen Tag auf dem Flur so unterhalten. Wahrscheinlich, oder? Mit diesen Abkürzungen.
Na ja, wenn du die Wahl hast zwischen Zentrum operative Kommunikation der Bundeswehr oder Z-Opcom BW, dann gehst du wahrscheinlich eher ins Set-Opcom.
Ja, aber dann könnte man sich ja zumindest die zu äh abzukürzenden Begriffe besser wählen, damit da lustigere Namen bei rauskommen. Also zentrum operative Kommunikation der Metaebene äh lässt sich zumindest zu ZOP-Komme äh zusammenwerfen.
Ich ich glaube, diese dieses BW-Kürzel lassen die dann im Hause auch weg. Ne, also du machst ja bei dir zu Hause, schreibst ja auch nicht mehr am Ende Punkt local dran. Also äh sagen die dann, die gehen halt ins ZOP kommen. ZOPCOM.
Zack. Ein Zock. Zock. Ja wir wir haben.
Zock, ZOK, heißt aber bestimmt irgendwas anderes. Drei drei Buchstabenabkürzungen.
Stimmt, die sind dann aber ganz besonders, ne?
Ließung in offenen Quellen.
Aber die Details des Forschungsprojektes sind zur geheimen Verschlusssache erklärt worden. Oh Mann, ey, das ist ein Land. Na ja, ähm,
immerhin werden hier noch Sachen zur geheimen Verschlusssache erklärt und man weiß wenigstens, dass es sie gibt in anderen Ländern, ist das ja anders. Ähm,
Der Bundesnachrichtendienst ähm möchte,
auch ja, wie wir wie wir schon berichtet haben, die Echtzeit-Analyse von Streaming-Daten äh durchführen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob also damit meinen sie wahrscheinlich was anderes, als als Video-Streaming.
Ja, die reden natürlich von diesen Texttreams, von den Timelines.
Konsumiert, das ist ja schon wieder so fast schon technischer Analytics äh Begriff, ja, dass wenn man da Zugang über das API erhält, dann erhält man ja einen Stream
und da strömt ja dann auch dieser ganze äh Textfluss dann auch schon ordentlich rein. Also das ist dann schon auch von der Datenmenge her durchaus vergleichbar Video-Stream.
Und sie möchten dann mit Hilfe statistischer Verwahren, Tendenzen, Trends und Auffälligkeiten erkennen. Und das Wichtige ist oder das Ziel ist, dass sie besonders krisenhafte Entwicklungen frühzeitig erkennen können.
Also das wollen sie gerne, ob sie das können, das äh sei mal dahingestellt.
Na ja, Twitter wird ja schon, also so eine Weltmeisterschaft hat ja dann doch schon irgendwie mal einen kleinen Peak in die Twitterstatistiken gemacht. Das war ja schon eine krisenhafte Entwicklung da. Streckenweise.
Ja, du meinst so das Faul an Neymar und so, ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Also was mich wundert ist, äh was mich,
warum ich das überhaupt mit aufgenommen habe, weil ich das Thema insgesamt eigentlich nicht wirklich meldenswert finde, also zumindest die Meldung als solche, kaum Melde und meldenswert finde. Ähm,
Das hat ein relativ großes Bohei in den Medien gegeben. Also es war irgendwie Spiegel Online groß und pipapo, ne? Und alle irgendwie, ja, jetzt will das Militär in unser Facebook rein. Und ähm und uns da ausforschen und.
Das ist ja auf jeden Fall schon mal eine ein Thema, dessen sich jetzt Spiegel Online vor einiger Zeit nicht unbedingt in dieser epischen Breite dann angenommen hätte.
Ähm andererseits scheint es auch jetzt kein
wirklich zu interessiert zu haben, ne, also die Bundeswehr mit ihren mit ihren komischen Abkürzungen, die haben ja sogar ein eigenes Wappen, ne. Hast du das mal gesehen in diesem heiße Artikel?
Das ist so ein Wappen wie Wappen so sind, ne, sie sehen aus wie ein Schild. Da ist irgendwie eine Pflanze drauf, ein Ritterkreuz oder also ist das ein Ritterkreuz oder dieses ist, glaube ich, das Bundeswehr-Logo. Dann irgendwie,
zwei Balken, wo so ein Pfeil durchgeht und der Schlüssel der Stadt Bremen, glaube ich.
Sieht zumindest so aus. Ist das in Bremen?
Ich weiß, ich kenne nur diesen Schlüssel der Stadt Bremen, der auf der Becks Bierflasche ist. Ich habe mir den jetzt im Detail nicht gemerkt. Das habe ich.
Du kennst das. Du kennst das nur aus dem Getränkemarkt sozusagen.
Na ja, diese diese Ritterkreuze kenne ich meistens von den Nazis oder von den äh von den Rockern. Den Schlüssel kenne ich von der Stadt Bremen und die linken beiden Symbole sagen mir nix.
Also, kurzer Gegencheck, äh er sieht dem Bremer Schlüssel ähnlich, es handelt sich aber nicht um denselben.
Haben sie das wäre schön gewesen.
Gleich äh herauszunehmen.
Keine Ahnung, wo, worauf sich dieser Schlüssel bezieht. Ja, ja, ich meine, so mit diesen Wappen und Abzeichen und so weiter, da da stehen sie halt total drauf, das ist dann halt einfach wie so ein Nerdshirt bei uns, also passt schon.
Ja, okay, aber also was, was ich um meinen Faden zurückzufinden? Klar, man denkt dann, ach, die Bundeswehr, ne, die nimmt die nimmt man ja jetzt irgendwie,
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das das Durchschnittsdeutsche Verhältnis zur Bundeswehr ist.
Naja ganz gut würde ich sagen.
Ganz gut, ne, weil wenn irgendwie irgendwie die Elbe über die Ufer tritt, dann legen sie Sandsäcke hin, da können sie nächsten zehn Jahre noch von erzählen, wie sie damals äh geholfen haben oder so, ne. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Also die.
Man kann, man kann jetzt ja der Bundeswehr ja auch kein besonders umstürzerisches äh Potential oder andere Neigungen äh unterstellen. Also es die haben ja nun schon seit seit ihrer Gründung sich
ganz ordentlich äh
benommen, sage ich mal so, im Großen und Ganzen. Da kann man dann im Einzelnen natürlich äh trefflich drüber diskutieren. Ich weiß ja auch jetzt gar nicht, ob du das überhaupt schon gesagt hast, aber worauf der Artikel ja auch hinweist, ist,
Diese Werkzeuge werden zumindest die Eigenaussage äh verwendet im Auslandsermittlungseinsatz. Ja,
nicht so ganz genau, ob sie da irgendwie afghanische Twitter-Streams,
auswerten, also inwiefern jetzt sagen wir mal ihre äh Hotspots, mit denen sie eigentlich tatsächlich grade zu tun haben, sich tatsächlich in solchen Netzwerken äh schon äh abbilden. Ja, das mag da auch alles noch Forschungscharakter haben.
Scheint doch eher vor.
Es ist sicherlich,
aus der militärischen Logik her auch nachvollziehbar zu sein, ja? Das sind halt Dinge, die passieren äh die beobachtet man um eine Einschätzung der Lage, nicht erst in dem Moment äh,
sich herleiten zu müssen, wenn die Lage schon außer Kontrolle ist, ne. Inwiefern solche Textströme tatsächlich auch als.
Auch alles wirklich als brauchbare Quelle anzusehen sind, das fällt mir ehrlich gesagt sehr schwer, das zu beurteilen
Dazu müsste man sich im Prinzip mal anschauen, wie
tatsächliche Eskalationen in den letzten Jahren sich dort niedergeschlagen haben und mit welchem Grad diese Analysemethode äh in der Lage gewesen wäre, da auch eine entsprechende Vorwarnung oder vor Informationen zu geben.
Ja, ich denke, man muss da jetzt vielleicht auch gar nicht denken, dass.
Sich ein Anschlag verhindert wird unbedingt, weil vorher rumgetwittert wird, aber vielleicht hilft denen das dabei, wenn sie da irgendwie in Afghanistan mit ihren rumfahren. Ähm
sich
mal zu gucken, was in der Ecke grade getwittert wird und ob die ob die Stimmung allgemein gerade gut ist oder ob man vielleicht grade mal besser in das andere Dorf fährt und da guckt.
Ja, also.
Keine Ahnung. Ne, aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist das Thema relativ groß aufgehängt, aber keiner kehrt.
Du meinst jetzt im Sinne der Medien.
Von den von den Lesern.
Zu wenig Kommentare oder was.
Hat sich jetzt, ich habe da jetzt keine große Aufregung,
Thema feststellen können.
Ja, finde ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt, ich meine, was machen sie schon? Sie machen halt das, was äh jeder Social Media Analyst halt auch macht,
Ja, ich meine, sie benutzt ja sogar die selben Tools, also äh jeder Damen bindende Hersteller äh hat da einen ähnlichen äh Blick auf diese Datenströmer, das äh dass das jetzt die Bundeswehr auch macht.
Könnten die doch mal jemanden fragen, der sich damit auskennt.
Ja, ich glaube, das Damenbinden jetzt nicht so in ihrem Fokus stehen werden.
Okay, also die Meldung musste irgendwie mit rein, weil sie groß war und äh wir halten sie für nach wie vor nichtig.
Unfallsommerloch ist und das muss ja auch irgendwie gefüllt werden,
Sogar hier, sogar hier.
Auch ein Sommerloch gefüllt hat, der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband. Der VZBV, denn der hat eine Klage angestrengt gegen Kabel Deutschland.
Wegen der Drossel, die Kabel Deutschland zur Anwendung bringt. Ähm das ist schon seit einiger Zeit bekannt,
Und da finde ich das also Kabel Deutschland bewirbt ja so Anschlüsse mit zehn bis hundert Megabit pro Sekunde,
Downstream, ne? Upstream sind die immer totlahm, oder? Diese Kabelanschlüsse, wenn ich das richtig.
Zumindest sind sie nicht auffallend schnell. Also das ja. Das ist ja generell das Problem, dass das eigentlich immer mit diesen ganzen Geschwindigkeiten immer nur äh in Bezug auf den Download geworben wird und man echt schon fünfmal hinschauen muss, bis man überhaupt weiß, was für Uploads da,
äh realistisch sind.
Und äh sie bewerben also zehn bis hundert Megabit pro Sekunde und haben dann eine Fußnote da drin und sagen, wenn du da irgendwie exzessives File Sharing machst,
dann drosseln wir dich beim Erreichen eines äh eines Grenzwertes auf hundert Kilo bitte.
Und wir die Drosseln allerdings nicht den gesamten Anschluss, sondern nur die Fight-Sharing-Anwendungen.
Das heißt, du wirfst irgendwie deinen Torent an, erreichst die Grenze, diese Grenze liegt bei sechzig Gigabyte pro Tag.
Ja? Und wenn du diese sechzig Gigabyte am erreicht hast am Tag, dann drossen sie dich auf hundert Kilobit und diese Drossel ist dann aber am nächsten Tag auch wieder weg.
Ähm.
Also sagen wir wie es ist, hier geht's um bitterend und ich vermute, es geht hier auch ausschließlich um Beton.
Also ja, alles andere ähm macht ja, ist, macht ja nicht so hohes
Volumen, beziehungsweise ist dann halt auch nicht mehr als Fightsharing eindeutig identifizierbar, ja. Und sie drosseln also quasi genau deinen, genau das Fallschirm, was du da machst,
Nur diese Ports und ähm.
Ab sechzig Gig am Tag war das das heißt da kommst du immer noch auf äh irgendwie annähernd äh zwei, eins Komma acht Terabyte oder sowas, ne, im im.
Ja, also ist jetzt auch kein.
Monat, die du falsch schenke.
Auch kein Limit, wo man sagen muss, dass,
ist ja jetzt jenseits von Gut und Böser, ja. Weil ähm also wir erinnern uns, wir hatten ja letzte oder vorletzte Ausgabe auch kurz diese Debatte über das O zwei Limit, ja, O zwei, DSL, Drossel,
was er bei dreihundert Gigabyte im Monat,
Griff bei Wiederholungen wohlgemerkt. Ähm hier reden wir immerhin schon vom sechsfachen ungefähr, dessen,
im Vergleichbaren Downloadbereich ungefähr, also gut, kann man jetzt sagen,
vielleicht ein bisschen schneller, Kabel Deutschland, vielleicht ist es aber auch nicht schneller, weil weiß man aber nicht so ganz genau, weil wenn man halt Kabel hat, dann teilt man sich eben die Bandbreite äh quasi immer mit seinen Nachbarn
und wenn man halt jetzt irgendwie nur so betont äh Menschen als Nachbarn hat, dann mag das vielleicht von äh Nachteil sein. Na ja, wer auch immer also diese Regelung
besteht, wird aber dann eben nur in kleingedruckten irgendwo erwähnt und dagegen hat dann der,
Verbraucher.
VZPV, Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband.
Verbraucherzentrale, Bundesverband, genau und ähm ja, die haben jetzt geklagt.
Genau und,
Kabel Deutschland sagt dann noch dazu, die diese Drossel reißen, hm, also in diesen Bereich reißen null Komma fünf Prozent der Kunden. Ja, also das haben sie auch noch zu ihrer Verteidigung vorgebracht, dass sie sagen, das betrifft ja kaum jemanden,
und sie haben dann ein Urteil kassiert, in dem der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband Recht bekommen hat.
Dass es sich dabei um irreführende Werbung handelt,
weil sie ihr Angebot Flatrate nennen. Das heißt, die Konsequenz ist Kabel Deutschland wird auf diese Drossel prominenter hinweisen müssen. Das Ganze ist ein Urteil des Landgerichts München eins
und noch nicht rechtskräftig. Das heißt, ähm Kabel Deutschland könnte sich jetzt überlegen, dagegen noch irgendwie
das in die nächste Instanz zu schleppen oder das Ding jetzt zu schlucken und nicht mehr in einer,
Note auf Seite zwei auf diese Drossel hinzuweisen, sondern das vielleicht prominent dazu groß dazuzuschreiben. Insgesamt finde ich das schon gut, dass es hier eine Frage nicht darum geht,
Nicht um die Drosselungspraktik geht, die wir ja beide, glaube ich, für halbwegs ähm,
halbwegs akzeptabel noch halten so.
Ja, geht schlimmer.
Geht schlimmer und verbirgt sich jetzt nicht eine äh
Also, streng genommen ist es natürlich genauer wie alles, was irgendwo eingreift, eine Verletzung der Netzneutralität, weil sie
jetzt irgendwie andere Angebote, die nicht über das bitteren Protokoll laufen bevorzugen und weil es, weil es auch nicht zulässig ist,
direkt mit illegal gleichzusetzen aber.
Das ist ja auch hier nicht das Entscheidende, sondern das Entscheidende ist, dass da dass da, dass so, so, wenn man in so einem Torwart ist, da geht schon richtig Bandbreite durch
Also wenn man da ähm wenn man da ein aktiver ist, dann schickt man sehr viele Daten an sehr viele Leute und das ist schon für so ein Netz äh eine Herausforderung.
Weil insbesondere eben bei diesen limitierten Upload äh Strecken
Das mag an der Stelle auch nochmal besonders tödlich sein, dass einfach diese inneren Asymmetrie, dieser Anschlüsse, insbesondere wenn sie dann eben auch noch über mehrere
Teilnehmer verteilt sind, ja, also bei der Telekom, wo ich jetzt so 'n Dedizierten Anschluss ans Netz habe mit meinem eigenen Kupferkabel, meinem DSL-Anschluss,
Da kann das eigentlich der Telekom äh mehr oder weniger egal sein, wenn ich jetzt meinen Upload
satuiere, weil das betrifft die anderen nur beschränkt einerseits, weil da ohnehin nicht so viel rüberkommt. B weil,
Ab dem Punkt, wo's an die Telekom übergeben ist, ohnehin ganz andere und dann eben auch vor allem im Wesentlichen symmetrische ähm Kapazitäten bereitstehen, die das einfach problemlos abfangen. Bei Kabel Deutschland,
kann es sehr wohl sein
so ein bisschen geraten, ne, dass wenn jetzt äh äh jemand, der einfach massiv die Upload-Performance dicht macht, dann macht er ja auch wirklich den kompletten Rückkanal für alle anderen
die da äh auch mit am selben Draht hängen, quasi mit Tod. Das fällt ja dann zwangsläufig wieder auf Kabel Deutschland zurück. Das ist halt ein Problem dieser Anschlusstechnik.
Ich hab ausgerechnet wenn sie sagen null Komma fünf Prozent der Kunden
Das äh Sinn, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht verrechnet habe, bei geschätzt vier Komma drei Millionen Internetkunden, die sie wohl bekannt gegeben haben fürs letzte Jahr, äh einundzwanzigtausend Leute, wo das greift.
Mhm. Ich also äh bei bei Kabel Deutschland ist es, wie du gerade sagst, aufgrund dieser Anschlusstechnik, du hast da halt einen,
auf der letzten Meile mehr schert medium und deswegen,
oder wahrscheinlich nicht nur auf der letzten Meile. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie dann sich da irgendwann mal mit vernünftigem Internet verbinden. Ähm du hast da auf jeden Fall mehr medium und du hast dann, die haben dann, haben mit sowas eher ein Problem,
Aber trotzdem, wenn es nur null Komma null fünf äh null Komma fünf Prozent der Kunden betrifft, kann man ja argumentieren, warum lasst.
Warte mal, null Komma fünf, achthundert null Komma fünf. Ich habe null Komma null fünf gerechnet. Dann äh sind's äh.
Mir kam die Zeit auch so um eine,
Zehner Potenz zu klein vor, aber egal, also null Komma fünf Prozent der, wenn es nur null Komma fünf Prozent der Kunden betrifft und das sagen ja alle, o2 sagt ja auch, ja, hier unsere Drossel, super geil, äh ist Fairness Vorteil,
betrifft nur ganz wenige Kunden.
Ja, warum machen sie sich denn überhaupt diesen Aufwand, ne, also ähm bei Kabel Deutschland jetzt mit dieser kann man das, glaube ich, noch, wie gesagt, auch Pech, gibt es da noch technische Gründe für und ähm die Drossel steht jetzt erstmal nicht im Verdacht, ähm,
eigenen Geschäftsmodellen äh Hand in Hand zu gehen,
Aber bei den anderen Anbietern sieht's ja anders aus. Ähm und da gab's einen sehr schönen Artikel von Aras Techniker, den ich jetzt auch mal,
verlinkt habe, der sich um die in der Netzzentralität der Netzwerk meine Güte, Netzneutralitätsdebatte der USA,
zu Wort melden und sagen, wenn die Internetservice Provider einerseits sagen, ja, hier ähm wir haben genug Kapazitäten, braucht euch keine Sorgen zu machen,
der hier gibt es keine keine Engpässe bei uns.
Und gleichzeitig noch sagen, ja, nur null Komma fünf Prozent der Nutzer sind von unseren äh
Drosselsperren äh betroffen, dann fragt man sich, warum sie's überhaupt machen, ne. Also das ist ja schon ganz interessant. Also deren Argumentation ist nach wie vor nicht schlüssig. Wie gesagt, jetzt mit der kleinen Ausnahme bei Kabel Deutschland, wo es da schon noch technischen Hintergrund gibt,
Aber ich bin äh,
Wie gesagt, es muss nicht immer nur um Netzneutralität gehen. Ähm hier geht es auch um eben Transparenz und Verbraucherschutz und es ist schon gut, wenn man möglichst früh ähm,
in diesem Bereich sich Urteile erkämpft, in denen klar gemacht wird, wie groß man als Betreiber ähm und wie transparent man auf solche,
technischen Limitierungen des Angebotes hinweisen muss, weil wir davon hoffentlich in der Zukunft zehren können, wenn immer mehr äh Netzneutralitätsbeschränkte Angebote.
Uns untergejubelt werden müssen und es aber immer groß dranstehen muss.
Ja, also äh ich bin ja schon bei vierzig, da da da muss man ja Dreisatz nicht mehr äh vollständig beherrschen. Ich habe mich zwar vorhin verrechnet, aber äh zu meinen Gunsten. Das heißt, meine Zahl stimmt da eigentlich.
Falschen Zahl falsch gerechnet und das richtige Ergebnis.
Ja genau, äh also so ist das, ne.
Da hat man in der Grundschule oder was, wo man noch den Rechenschritt zeigen muss, sondern trotzdem, glaube ich, so ein bisschen Abzug bekommen. Das erinnere ich mich noch. Da gab's dann Debatten, weiß, da gab's dann so Spezies, die haben äh ähm.
Den Rechnerweg falsch abgeschrieben oder den Rechenweg falsch hingeschrieben, aber so unten drunter die richtige Zahl, ne.
Falsch gerechnet, genau, ja.
Aber die richtige Zahl konnten sie noch bei mir abgucken. Ja und dann war die Debatte groß mit der Lehrerin, aber da steht das richtige Ergebnis. Ja, aber du hast falsch gerechnet. Ja, ich habe das richtige Ergebnis da stehen. So geht das so. Der kleine Tim.
Gut, in diesen Zeiten umgeht man dann einfach zu Wolfram Alpha und gibt es einfach genauso ein, wie es einem gerade so durch den Kopf geht und der macht dann den Rest. Das ist schon mal ganz gut. Aber das sind halt tatsächlich irgendwie so knapp. Einundzwanzigtausend
ähm Leute, die das angeblich hier nur betrifft. Äh ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob du's schon erwähnt hast, aber äh was das ja im Prinzip auch bedeutet ist, dass Kabel Deutschland ja äh seine Kanäle auch,
extrem akribisch überwachen kann. Also die technische
Beobachtungsleistungen, die das Equipment durchzuführen in der Lage ist, geht halt so weit, dass sie bitteren Protokoll heraus
pulen kann. Und das ist nun so einfach auch nicht, weil man ist ja vorhin äh die entsprechenden Ports. Bei Bitterungen gibt's diese entsprechenden
Ports. In dem Sinne ja gar nicht, sondern das sind ja alles dynamisch äh gewählte Ports, teilweise äh
ist ja der Traffic dann auch noch verschlüsselt, das heißt auch noch nicht mal so ohne weiteres als solcher zu erkennen,
Da gibt's dann sicherlich Houristiken, mit denen man sagen kann, nur hier ist jetzt so viel äh verschlüsselt auf komischen Ports, das kann ja nur bitteren sein, ja, so als Ausschlusskriterium. Ich weiß nicht so ganz
genau, wie's
funktioniert, aber das ist halt so die Technik. Also diese Deck Inspection, die also generell eigentlich so auch die Überwachungs äh Technologie, Voraussetzung äh ist, zumindest für so kritische Infrastrukturen.
Die kommt dann hier genauso zum Einsatz. Eben zur Systemoptimierung nett auszudrücken.
Ja. Ähm ich weiß nicht genau, ob das, ob du schon in dem Bereich Deep,
Inspection gehen muss, weil du ja eigentlich das doch schon, also die Portbereiche
wenn du dir die sind, glaube ich, schon größtenteils erkennbar, ja? Oder du nimmst halt einfach alles, was nicht ein definierter Port
und und guckst, wenn der wenn der Nutzer auf einmal auf allen möglichen Ports durch die Gegend ballert und er erstaunlich viel Upload hat, dann erkennt man schon, dass er da,
torentifiziert so, aber ähm.
Naja, aber besser ist er, wenn man sich eine Headde anschaut, kann man da sehr, sehr, sehr sicher sein, ne.
Ja, also wie sie's machen, wie sie's im Detail machen, weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nur, wie sie's berechnen, denn ich kenne zufällig denjenigen, der dieses System gebaut hat.
Oh, guck an, was du für Freunde hast, so.
Da wunderst du dich den Diss auch dein Freund. Ähm.
Entschuldigung, habe nichts gesagt.
Ja, es ist halt so ein so ein Bucket System, ne, wo man dann, wo du dann irgendwann in so andere äh Klassen der der Drossel kommst. Egal, also äh wie gesagt, insgesamt eher ein ähm,
ein Teil der äh der des Verbraucherschutzes, den ich.
Genau. Ja, die Frage ist natürlich, was was äh wächst da jetzt dadraus? In gewisser Hinsicht reicht das ja auch wieder in diese ähm generelle Problematik der Flatrate
Bewerbung hinein, ja? Wir hatten das äh ja, dass die Telekom im Prinzip ja schon
umgesetzt hat, aber im Prinzip ja gesagt hat, okay, wir streichen jetzt dieses Flatrate äh an den Stellen, wo wir äh tatsächlich drosseln. Später haben sie ja dann gesagt, wir streichen jetzt auch das Drosseln.
Trotzdem, vielleicht fällt wie auch immer, aber äh das ist ja äh eigentlich so ein Ärgernis und ich denke, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe, dass sich der Verbraucherverband und letztlich dann auch das
Gericht ja im Wesentlichen an der falschen Deklaration und nicht so sehr an der Tatsache, dass das überhaupt getan wird. Äh stört.
Soweit zum letzten Thema kommen.
Können wir machen. Das sind hier unsere Minister sind wieder ganz vorne.
Da wollte ich dich mal fragen, unser Minister, ne? Die feine Herrenminister, ähm der, der Mars, ne?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was ich vor dem halten soll. Manchmal macht der was sehr äh manchmal sagt er sehr intelligente Dinge. Und äh kündigt an, sich äh Problemen anzunehmen.
Die ich auch äh so sehe und verspricht sinnvolle Lösungen. Manchmal labert der totalen ähm Quark.
Ja. Du bist ja schon ein ganz guter Schnitt, finde ich, für so einen führenden Politiker.
Für ihn jetzt. Also er hat ja jetzt.
So generell, so für für seine Branche äh ist das ja schon ein ganz guter Schnitt. Das hat er also überhaupt mal.
Dass er was sagt.
Nachvollziehbares sagt.
Ja, dann sagt er was Sinnvolles nachvollziehbar ist und dann kommt äh Thomas de Maizire und sagt, ey Heiko, äh hast du Fieber? Und dann äh kommt er irgendwie eine Woche später wieder und musste irgendwie sich wieder äh,
wieder rechtfertigen was anderes erzählen. Diesmal hat ihn wurde er interviewt,
zu vielen verschiedenen Themen unter anderem zu dem Thema, dass ja die Aufenthaltserlaubnis von in Russland
formell in wenigen Tagen auslaufen wird. In wenigen Tagen heißt's so ungefähr jetzt, weil wir Ende Juli haben
und ähm es hat sich aber schon vor vielen Monaten angekündigt, dass jetzt da eine Verlängerung dieser Aufenthaltsgenehmigung ähm
nicht mit mit großen Blockaden von Wladimir Putin einhergehen wird.
So dass ihr im Zweifelsfall einfach dort bleiben kann, aber unser Justizminister, der Schlaubi Schlumpf, erklärt,
Doktor Snorden, äh nee, ist ja noch gar nicht Doktor. Ist ja inzwischen Doktor. Er hat jetzt eher einen Doktor bekommen, nee, ne, er hat.
Also nicht da, wo es ursprünglich angekündigt wurde, aber ich glaube, irgendeine andere Uni ist wieder nachgezogen, war's nicht sogar eine Berliner Uni? Ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht.
Snowden ist Snorden. SNON solle doch ähm.
In die USA reisen und ähm sich dort stellen.
Denn sonst wird er immer auf der Flucht sein vor den amerikanischen Strafverfolgungsbehörden.
Also unabhängig davon, dass wir tatsächlich ja schon vor einiger Zeit äh vor einigen Folgen auch berichtet haben, dass der gute Anwalt von Snowden, der deutsche Anwalt, Herr Karlek, ähm,
sich auch über die Option mit den Amerikanern unterhält, was denn wäre, wenn Snowden mal in die USA käme,
und dass Norden ja auch gesagt hat, dass er grundsätzlich natürlich daran interessiert wäre, nochmal irgendwie seine Familie wieder zu sehen, aber eben es ihm dabei auch dann wahrscheinlich eher um seine Familie geht und die möchte er wahrscheinlich äh,
unter anderen Bedingungen wiedersehen, als es jetzt vielleicht zum Beispiel Chelsea Manning äh möglich ist, ja? Also ich weiß nicht genau, was dieser Rat soll.
Heiko Maas. Ich würde äh Snowden sagen, da nochmal eine Meinung von einem unabhängigen Dritten einzuholen. Das ist wahrscheinlich das.
Ja, also ich meine, SPD-Politiker in der Zeit, wo sie gerade in einer großen Koalition mit der CDU sind, ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich jetzt so die Quelle ist, an der man sich groß äh orientieren sollte, ja. Also.
Also die Ehrendoktor würde da in Rostock, die ist irgendwie so auf den letzten Metern äh verhindert worden, ja. Äh ich glaube, die einzigen Ehren,
Mitgliedschaften, die bisher erfolgreich aus Deutschland angetragen wurden, waren die der Freien Universität Berlin und die des Gras-Computer-Clubs.
Hat er dir ein oh, das sah. Junge, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, Junge, Junge, Junge. Da müssen wir mal gucken, ob der die überhaupt schon angenommen hat.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich habe erst vor einiger Zeit das äh Schreiben mitverfasst, indem wir ihm uns angedient haben.
Haben.
Na, die wird ja schon angenommen haben. Ich muss ja nochmal gucken.
Wehe nicht, sonst unterstützen wir sofort eine Auslieferung.
Sonst geben wir dir den Rat, dass du.
Genau. Ja, na ja gut, ähm.
Also nicht, dass jetzt hier irgendwie ähm irgendwelche ähm.
Irgendwelche Gerüchte entstehen. Also diese die Ehrenmitgliedschaft muss natürlich angedient werden. Man kann jemanden nicht gegen seinen Willen zum Ehrenmitglied machen. Und ähm,
Das ist also auch ein formaler Akt, der damit einhergeht und ich bin gerade nicht hundertprozentig im Bilde über den,
über den Status dieses formalen Aktes, weil die Kommunikation mit Edwards Norden äh sich relativ äh schwierig gestaltet.
Ja, ich habe ja auch neulich irgendwie versucht anzurufen und so ist nicht rangegangen.
Ist nicht dran gegangen, ne? Der geht echt manchmal nicht dran.
Der ist echt schlimm, ey, Sau.
Auf meine auf meine Facebook-Nachrichten, antwortet der auch.
Ja, irgendwie, immer ganzen Abend irgendwie, ja, Bier ausgeben und so und dann auch nicht mal rangehen, also so geht's ja nun auch nicht.
Echt? Und dann auf einmal ist er nicht mehr dein Freund auf WhatsApp.
Oh Gott. Hat mich entfreundet.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was ich was man zu dieser Meldung noch groß äh sagen kann. Ich halte das jetzt für eine der etwas äh weniger qualifizierten Ratschläge, äh die man so erhalten kann in seiner Situation.
Weil das äh Mister Putin äh in gerade in diesen Zeiten äh ihnen jetzt ähm des Landes äh verweist, das kann ich mir kaum vorstellen. Äh einerseits
weil er das wahrscheinlich ja selber einfach noch für zu wertvoll ansieht, für so seine Druck als Druckoption,
B, weil selbst wenn er das wollen würde, würde er wahrscheinlich so dermaßen äh Gegenwind bekommen aus seiner Hardliner-Fraktion, dass er das auch nicht so ohne Weiteres,
ignorieren kann, ne? Also weil jetzt den Amerikanern jetzt so ein Geschenk auf dem Tablett zu äh liefern, ist natürlich in der aktuellen politischen Situation einfach vollkommen undenkbar.
Würde ich auch so erstmal sagen, ne?
Insofern ist er da in Anführungsstrichen
sicher, inwiefern das für ihn äh irgendwann nochmal eine nennenswerte Ausreiseoption äh ergibt, lässt sich einfach nicht sagen
irgendwie kleben die ganzen Whistleblower, kleben irgendwie alle in irgendwelchen Staaten fest. Das scheint so ein bisschen das Schicksal zu sein, dieser Fraktion.
Zumindest derzeit.
Aber äh noch kurz das Heiko Maas, der springt auch auf diesen äh Beweis äh auf diesen auf diese Schote an. Ähm Snowden habe keine Beweise geliefert.
Ist natürlich ein echt guter Witz ist, ne.
Der hat darüber erzählt, aber er hat keine Beweise geliefert, erklärt uns. Ähm,
der Justizminister. Meine Güte. Naja, okay. Tim, wollen wir wollen wir uns nochmal zurücklehnen,
und ein bisschen äh über diese dieses Zeit, die wir erlebt haben äh in diesem Jahr äh blicken, bevor wir jetzt ins Sommerloch fallen.
Machen. Wann fing gerade Herr Snowden an mit seinem Tanz? Das war doch jetzt just im letzten Juli, ne? Wir haben jetzt gerade so auf äh satuiert zwölf Monate Berichterstattung zurück.
Also ich glaube auch so wie es genau vor einem Jahr durfte er dann auch in Moskau gestrandet sein. War das so?
Nee, das muss dann, der, das hat ja noch äh der war ja länger dort, der war ja, glaube ich, vierzehn Tage in dem Flughafen, in dem Transitbereich ähm und hat dann ja irgendwann Asyl bekommen. Und wenn das jetzt genau
äh ein oder Tempo ist temporäres Asyl mit Aufenthaltsgewebe. Wenn das jetzt jetzt ausläuft, dann ähm,
ist davon auszugehen, dass er schon einige Zeit länger in in Russland ist als ähm.
Dreiundzwanzigster Juni zwanzig dreizehn, also so vor dreizehn Monaten ist er in in Moskau gestrandet.
Aber die ging's jetzt gar nicht nur um Snoden, oder?
Mir geht's so um das um die um das Gesamtbild. Ich ich versuche mich immer ab und zu mal zurückzulehnen
und so zu überlegen, was so mit dieser Netzpolitik eigentlich passiert, ne? In welche Richtung sich das entwickelt, mal so wieder in das große Bild zu blicken
und meistens endet das damit, dass wir irgendwann nachts um fünf äh entscheiden, dass wir jetzt möglichst in Klappsparten und,
fünf Kabel investieren müssen, weil wir uns möglichst bald das, dessen eigene neue Internet äh legen müssen. Ja und in den in den Untergrund müssen
Aber vielleicht ist ja die äh
die äh die Großwetterlage inzwischen besser, ja? Und da wollte ich mal so ein bisschen die Zeit nutzen, vielleicht ein bisschen auf die Meterebene von der Metaebene darauf zu blicken.
Die Großwetterlage. Tja, ich weiß es nicht. Also ich habe so nicht so den Eindruck, dass sich jetzt unter den Geheimdiensten irgendwie der Eindruck verstärkt hat, dass es bisschen übertreiben.
Und auch nicht bei den Regierungen. Ich denke, da ist einfach die diese Logik der der Notwendigkeit, der gegenseitigen Spionage ist einfach nach wie vor präsent,
Die einzigen, die jetzt wirklich äh da inhaltlich, wirklich ähm nachgelernt haben, das ist halt so hm ein gewisser Teil der Öffentlichkeit,
gewisser Teil der Öffentlichkeit, der wirklich in der Lage ist,
Informationen auch an sich heranzulassen, der auch bereit dazu ist, sie an sich heranzulassen. Ich denke, dass viele dieser komplexen Thema da auch einfach,
Ignoriert wird einfach von einem großen Teil, so wie wir.
Themen sagen.
Alle,
alle in der Lage sind, bestimmte bestimmte Meldungen und wiederholte Berichte von bestimmten Dingen einfach immer wieder zu ignorieren. Das ist einfach,
das gehört auch irgendwie einfach dazu, weil man ja überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist oder die meisten Leute zumindest nicht in der Lage sind alles.
Überhaupt zu verarbeiten. Meine wenn du dir jetzt sozusagen über sämtliche Zusammenhänge dieses Planetens Gedanken machst, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich ohnehin depressiv
Und ähm deswegen blendet man das eben aus. Und diese Geheimdienstnummer mit diesem Überwachen, das ist halt einfach nach wie vor alles so körperlos und alles so wenig spürbar,
das einfach dieses äh Entsetzen einer intellektuellen Elite da,
Sehr begrenzt verfängt und das war am Anfang dieser Geschichte so, das ist jetzt auch äh zum Zwischenstand so,
Dazu kommt eben, dass man sich auch noch in dieser ganzen Kette irgendwie abnutzt, also wenn du jetzt heute mit einem Artikel rauskommst mit neues Snowden-Dokumente, wieder irgendwas ganz Unglaubliches. Dokumentiert.
Kriegst du halt einfach nur noch ein gepflegtes ist halt so, ja. Ist halt nicht das zu sagen am besten, ich sage nur das ist mein Eindruck.
Insofern bin ich mir auch nicht sicher, inwiefern da jetzt ein ein Lernprozess eingesetzt hat, aber ich habe auch nicht den Eindruck, dass dass die Politik sich jetzt sonderlich unter Feuer sieht, sondern das ist irgendwie immer noch so in diesem,
was nicht aussieht, wie ein äh äh Fünf-Zentner-Steinblock, der gerade mit hundert Stundenkilometern äh in hundert Metern Höhe auf mich herniederauscht, so. Das sind Themen, die kann man auch irgendwie noch eine Sekunde später behandeln.
Ist halt alles immer äh aufwandsgetrieben. Und was haben wir jetzt für eine Großwetterlage? Ich meine, wir haben auch eine eine Kriegs.
Situation weltweit, die gerade einfach auch eine ganz andere Bedeutung hat. Beziehungsweise teilweise auch natürlich äh diese Vorgehensweisen in gewisser Hinsicht für viele sicherlich auch legitimiert,
Du schaust dir an, Europas Umgebung brennt, ja? Wir haben einen Krieg in der Ukraine, wir haben einen Krieg,
in Syrien,
in Libanon ist er nie so ganz vorbei wir haben jetzt gerade aktuell wieder eine kriegerische Auseinandersetzung zwischen Israel und den Palästinensern. Wir haben einen Krieg im Irak.
Äh in Libyen, Ägypten, okay, äh hat sich jetzt wieder beruhigt, aber nach was für einer Phase, ja, also allein
Tunesien äh hat von diesen revolutionären Staaten der letzten zwei, drei Jahre äh halbwegs eine Spur gefunden, wo man sagen kann, da äh geht's zumindest jetzt nicht komplett gegen die Wand.
Und und das ist so die Situation mit mit der wir uns gerade auseinandersetzen und das finde ich schon ganz schön tough,
und äh wir haben das jetzt gesehen, gut, ich meine, Bundeswehr, Social Media, das ist jetzt,
Das ist das ist kleine Fische, ja? Äh aber versetzt sich mal so in die Lage eines äh durchschnittlichen
ähm oder vielleicht auch eines überdurchschnittlichen gebildeten Amerikaners, der vielleicht auch so ein bisschen so diesen Weltblick zumindest so weit hat, dass er, dass er irgendwie weiß, welche Form Deutschland auf einer Nachrichtenkarte haben soll und wo Syrien ist, auf dem Globus. Ähm,
dass äh die dann einfach sagen, äh hier, was wollt ihr irgendwie? Die halbe Welt brennt, so, ja.
Wir haben hier mal echt andere Sorgen und wenn wir nicht die ganze Zeit,
sind, wenn wir nicht, wenn wir nicht irgendwie die Master sind, dann kommt irgendwie Putin und äh schnappt sich einfach ein Stück Land.
Ich meine, hat er jetzt gemacht, trotz
NSA, Aufklärung, alles irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was die Amerikaner da gemacht haben, ob sie's geduldet haben, ob sie's am kommen sehen, äh nichts dagegen tun konnten oder ob sie's am Kommen sehen und die falschen Maßnahmen ergriffen haben oder ob sie's einfach nicht am kommen sehen, weiß ich nicht. Ja, man kann natürlich jetzt viel argumentieren,
dass das Ganze äh nicht geholfen hat, aber äh das kann man auch nur dann vergleichen, wenn man im Prinzip das Szenario ohne
diese diesen Versuch, die Welt zu beobachten parallel noch vergleichen könnte, was natürlich unmöglich ist
Ich sage ja auch nur, es ist für mich nachvollziehbar,
Dass manche Leute das nicht in dem selben Maße denken wie wir das denken, weil wir senken das natürlich auch sehr idealistisch. Wir gehen da sehr ähm mit so einer Grundhaltung ran mit ja Überwachung ist an sich schon mal schlecht, weil es schränkt ja meine Freiheit ein.
Richtig und und und nachvollziehbar
letzten Endes zählt aber da irgendwie das ja. Das X hat halt irgendwie acht Punkte und das E hat nur einen und und und für jeden sind irgendwie äh die Worte einfach unterschiedlich viel äh wert so und äh
der eine ist halt irgendwie die Freiheit äh äh jederzeit äh unbeobachtet in den Busch zu pinkeln irgendwie äh wichtiger
und im anderen der definiert diese Freiheit eben eher also als Produkt des der Gesamtsituation und ist halt bereit da
Opfer einzugehen oder sagen wir mal einfach andere Prioritäten äh zu setzen und eben einer einer Machtstruktur, die man ja auch äh Vertrauen gegenüber bringt, Form des Staates, des des
ne? Repräsentanz der der Demokratie des gewählten Apparats äh dem äh diesem Machtmonopol auch den entsprechenden Raum zu geben, äh die Entscheidung eben so zu fällen, wie sie das für richtig halten.
Andererseits glaube ich auch, dass in den USA ganz konkret einfach diese Dimension dessen, was von der NSA betrieben wird, so auch überhaupt nicht gesehen wurde. Und teilweise wahrscheinlich auch jetzt noch nicht unbedingt gesehen,
wird und das es sehr wohl sein kann, dass,
Ist so ein politischen Backlash gibt, das zumindest so eine, so eine, so eine,
dass die unaufhörliche Steigerung dieses Exzesses äh zumindest in gewissem Maße gedrosselt wird. Ja, ist so ein bisschen wie äh,
wir machen etwas weniger Schulden als im letzten Jahr, ja? So.
Wir decken den Anstieg der neu.
Ist nicht, ist nicht sonderlich reflektiert, aber wenn du mich so fragst, dass es das ist so ein bisschen das, was mir so vom Gefühl her so entgegenkommt.
Finde ich gut. Das mal so auch äh zur Aussprache gebracht zu haben. Ich würde sagen, das kann ich auch so stehen lassen einfach mal.
Du meinst ja, kommen dir jetzt gar keine anderen Gedanken.
Nee, das hat mich, das hat mich jetzt erst, nee, ich fand das jetzt gut, das auch mal so einfach ähm nee, finde ich, würde ich einfach gerne so stehen lassen.
Weil wir haben uns ja hier am Anfang so ein bisschen gerühmt so Nachrichtenlager auch immer äh etwas unaufgeregt äh ähm betrachten zu wollen.
Ist uns häufig auch wir waren immer bemüht. Wir waren stets bemüht.
Es ging nicht irgendwie äh nicht nicht immer so, ja? Aber wahrscheinlich ist es halt auch immer ganz gut da äh den Dampfkessel auch mal ein bisschen abzulassen, worauf er mal,
so sehen zu können, ne. Mal schauen, ich denke, es ist einfach eine kritische Begleitung ist jetzt einfach äh weiterhin erforderlich. Und ich denke, dass dass die, zumindest in Deutschland, die
die Politik zumindest schon mal so weit in halb acht Stellung gegangen ist, dass sie begriffen hat, dass das jetzt kein Thema ist, was man beliebig überstrapazieren kann.
Und ähm da der Snowden Eiertanz ist sicherlich noch lange nicht vorbei. Ähm,
Ich denke auch, dass sehr wohl sein kann, dass noch ähm,
sich durch Leaks äh da Dinge ergeben können, denen wir so noch gar nicht gerechnet haben und die unter Umständen auch so einen die Involviertheit äh äh Europas,
Nur Deutschlands. Die involviertheit in Europa, in Europas dieses, dieses ganze System. Wir haben meine Britannien sowieso, ne, aber was weiß ich,
alles noch mit äh reingezogen werden könnte. Hm, dass wir einfach auch noch deutlicher sehen werden, was glaube ich,
so ein bestimmter äh äh Gruppe aus unserem Umfeld auch schon immer so gesehen hat. Dass dieser gesamte geheimdienstliche Apparat eigentlich so eine eigene Welt ist in dieser Welt,
dass diese ganzen Geheimdienste sich untereinander irgendwie fast auch noch näher stehen als als die Nationen und Völker äh das tun,
was ja auch teilweise ja überhaupt nicht tut, weil die einfach in so einer ganz anderen äh Logik sind und das, dass ich vielleicht auch in diesem Bereich so eine,
Macht Balance auf eine Art und Weise, Raum greift, wie wir das teilweise auch gar nicht verstehen.
Ja, dieses ganze Hin und Her, mit wer gibt jetzt wem, wie Daten und so? Das ist teilweise auch Spielchen sind. Das ist teilweise auch,
ähm ja, ganz plumpe Tauschhandel sind so im Sinne von, na ja, klar machen wir das, ja, aber damit verhindern wir, dass wir das und das tun müssen,
war so ganz einfach daher gesagt. Ist natürlich unvermittelbar so etwas,
und ähm zeigt natürlich diese Problematik von ähm Geheimdiensten als solchen, ne? Äh ich weiß nicht, hatten überhaupt diese Postmeldung, die war ja auch wieder ganz großartig.
Existenz von Geheimdiensten Hauptgrund für die Existenz von Geheimdiensten oder Existenz anderer Geheimdienste. Ja.
Ja, also und und da steckt so viel Wahrheit drin. Das ist das ist das ist überhaupt gar keine Spaß mehr. Ich habe sowieso beim letzten Zeit das Gefühl, dass es sozusagen die Essenz, ja, irgendwo. Ähm.
Stell dir mal vor, du du machst jetzt einen neuen Start so. Dir schenkt jetzt jemand eine Insel,
irgendwo wird jetzt hier äh was abgespalten, was keinerlei weitere äh Verwendung mehr hat hier irgend so ein Stück von Grönland oder keine Ahnung hier oder wir die Hacker schnappen sich irgendwie die Süd-Sahara,
So und jetzt jetzt fängst du halt an und bist jetzt mal ein Start. Dann kriegst du auch wieder eine top level Domain. Geil, endlich mal wieder coole URLs,
So und jetzt was musst du sozusagen so deine,
Außenweltbeziehung irgendwie an Start kriegen. Und dann wirst du wahrscheinlich schnell feststellen, dass du einfach mal so von Schlapphüten umringt bis in null Komma nix. Ja, die doch einfach mal,
Was du da auch immer treibst, komplett irgendwie einfach abschnorchen. Ich tue sie einfach, ist einfach da, überall stehen sie hinter jedem Baum, hinter jeder Litfaßsäule. Der dritte Mann und äh natürlich auch auf deinen Kommunikationswegen.
Was tust du dagegen?
Ja. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man dann sehr schnell auf so eine Logik kommt wie, hm, wir müssen uns hier mal ganz geheim mal in so einem Raum treffen und zusehen, dass wir diesen Raum irgendwie nicht abhörbar machen.
Ja? Und dann bist du in null Komma nix wahrscheinlich auch bei deinem kleinen Geheimdienst. Ja, ist äh,
die Welt und die Realität ist immer so eine Sache. Willst du das jetzt auch einfach so stehen lassen oder fällt dir dann auch was dazu ein?
Nee, das würde, da würde ich schon mal was zu sagen, weil die ähm also.
Geheimdienste bleiben ja zumindest in dem, was sie uns also was sie nach außen erzählen, wofür sie meinen zu arbeiten.
Dann doch die Wirkungsnachweise schuldig, ne?
Also ich denke, dass es zweifelsohne so ist, dass sie auch natürlich.
Ganz andere Ziele verfolgen, ne, dass eben ähm die Frage der Wirtschaftsspionage eine,
zentrale und präsente ist, genauso wie es die Frage der Spionage und Wirtschaftsspionage Abwehr natürlich ist.
Ähm aber das Entscheidend Ärgerliche an dieser ganzen Geheimdienstsache.
Ist ja dann doch, dass sie eigentlich uns zum Feind haben und dass sie das, was sie uns an Werten für unsere Gesellschaft versprechen, verteidigen zu wollen.
Sehr eindeutig unterwandern, ja? Also sie sind das Gegenteil von dem, wofür man ähm,
zu stehen oder zu kämpfen, ja? Also ich bin mir sicher zu auf diese gesamte ähm
auf diese gesamte Russland äh Situation, zu der ich immer wieder versuche, mich einzulesen, aber zu der ich einfach keine äh ausreichende äh Scheckung selber aufbaue, wo ich immer dann auf den,
auf die Einschätzung von anderen äh angewiesen bin, um meinen Horizont zu erweitern, äh da gibt's ja eine komplett äh.
Komplett schöne Sicht dadrauf, in der das halt auch alles äh Sinn macht, was der äh was Putin da äh veranstaltet,
und ähm ist jetzt auch alles andere als dass wir hier grade, dass hier grade die rote Gefahr droht aus ausm Osten oder so, ne, also ähm.
Bin mir da nicht so sicher,
oder mein, mein Hauptproblem ist eigentlich, ich würde soweit folgen, dass man als Staat wahrscheinlich einen Geheimdienst braucht, um irgendwie seine seine sein Wissen oder seine,
Seine diplomatische Situation akribisch ein genau einschätzen zu können, Verhandlungspositionen zu stärken, ähm
geschickt zu agieren, nicht sich irgendwelche ärgerliche Situationen oder äh bewaffnete Konflikte einzuhandeln. Und was nicht alles?
Aber mein Eindruck ist, dass das nicht die Aufgabe ist, die Geheimdienste in letzter Zeit tatsächlich erfüllen. Ich halte,
den die Haupt das,
Hauptwirkung von Geheimdiensten gerade für eine ähm andere als eine friedenstiftende.
Ja nun.
Und da denke ich, dass.
Ja
Äh zeigt ja auch grade die von dir angesprochene brennende Welt, äh dass das alles irgendwie,
nicht vernünftig funktioniert. Ja, also zumindest nicht äh mit den Zielen, die uns da versprochen wurden. Oder mit denen diese äh Geheimdienste uns uns gegenüber beworben wurden. Wenn man sich anschaut irgendwie ähm,
Israel hat ja äh relativ ähm,
effektive und gut ausgestattete Geheimdienste, ne, Mozart und Shinbette. Ähm.
Die auch nicht in der Lage sind ähm,
irgendwie signifikant da mal zu zu einer friedlicheren Situation beizutragen. Ganz im Gegenteil, es gibt ja diesen, jetzt ist mir grade der Name natürlich wieder entfallen. Es gibt ja mehrere ehemalige Leiter des Schinbet, die sich schon seit,
vor, ja, wann war das vor ein, zwei Jahren ähm,
zu Wort gemeldet haben mit mit halt klarer Kritik an der an der Politik äh Israels und so, ne, also ist jetzt nicht in Israel Palästina Konflikt hier aufmachen, aber das ist wirklich mal ein Geheimdienst oder das sind zwei Geheimdienste,
die ganz kleiner in der in der Krisenregion agieren, die ganz klar ähm,
äh der Hauptauftrag haben, Schaden von dem von dem von der äh Nation abzuwenden, die zu deren Schutz sie einberufen sind. Die haben eine ganz klare Aufgabe und die haben alle Mittel dafür, ja? Und die kriegen's auch nicht hin.
Ja gut, ich meine, sie sind äh sicherlich auch nicht omnipotent, ne. Ähm,
Was ist vielleicht die Frage des will man Geheimdienst haben oder nicht? Meine ist natürlich ein bisschen müßig, weil wir leben natürlich jetzt in einer Welt, wo de facto quasi jeder,
einen hat auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise. Heute stellen wir mal vor hier, was weiß ich, es passiert mal was ganz Unerwartetes äh
keine Ahnung, hier die Berliner Piraten äh benennen sich um, ja? Und kommen irgendwie äh äh auf den Namen Facebook-Partei und da klicken dann alle mal auf Like, weil das macht man ja immer so bei Facebook,
so, ja.
So, jetzt irgendwie Martin Delius ist jetzt irgendwie Kanzler. Äh Oliver Höfinhoff wird irgendwie für die Bundeswehr zuständig und so und äh Pavel Meier wird Geheimdienstkoordinator und das wird mal so beschlossen,
Okay, wir machen das jetzt mal hier alles mal auf. Ja, ich meine, würde selbst
in der Konstellation dann erstmal noch nicht so äh passieren, weil wahrscheinlich einfach tonnenweise kompromat aus den Schränken geholt wird, um diese Situation
möglichst so äh Container, ne, aber ist einfach mal nur so irgend so eine Konstellation, eine politische Konstellation, uns auch so eine Gesamtmenge und so eine allgemeine äh Stimmung in der
Bevölkerung vorstellen, wo er alle nur noch schreien soll jetzt, aber hier mal hundert Prozent Transparenz,
würdest du auf einmal versuchen diesen Laden quasi den Geheimdienst nicht mehr geheim zu führen? Ich freue mich, ob das überhaupt funktionieren kann oder was,
was zu oder.
Der muss äh.
Zu sagen davon wäre, der.
Also den, den kannst du natürlich nicht aufmachen, ja, das äh das wusste ja schon die Stasi, du musst halt dann schreddern, wenn die Tür da aufgeht, ne, das ist klar.
Okay, oder so? Machen wir's mal anders. Nehmen wir mal nicht andere Leute so. Angenommen, du bist jetzt Bundeskanzler. So, und zwar so ein richtiger mit irgendwie sechzig Prozent Wahlergebnis,
Ja, Treuden Abgeordneten in der Regierungsfraktion, den er alle schon irgendwie mit fuffzehn schon mal ein Bier gesoffen hast, alle auf Linie und so, ne? Was,
Masse mit deinem Geheimdienst. Hast du einen Tach? Ihr seid alle entlassen? Ja? Oder was.
Nömt, also als wir uns Bundeskanzler würde ich ja sowieso, aber das hat vielleicht auch mit meinen äh persönlichen und beruflichen Interessen zu tun, jetzt irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass einfach die Infrastruktur und die Kommunikationsmethoden abgesichert werden. Ja, also,
zuerst mal meine, das machen sie jetzt gerade auch, aber äh dann auch natürlich die der Bevölkerung,
Also ich ich habe halt keine, ich bin nach wie vor nicht in Sorge vor Terroristen,
ich halte die nach,
oberflächlicher und nach eingehender statistischer Betrachtung für einen der unwahrscheinlichsten Schadenstodes oder sonst was Ursachen in meinem Leben. Ich bin äh habe größere Angst vor äh Infektionskrankheiten,
Ähm Autounfällen und äh weiß ich, Malaria, ja,
als vor vor Terroristen.
Hm, was ist mit Wirtschaftsspionage.
Deswegen sage ich ja, IT-Sicherheit würde ich das würde ich alles hochfahren, da würde ich jetzt das ganze Geld hinwerfen. Das wird alles zugemacht und sonst was und die,
Problem ist ja, warum das nicht geschieht, ist, weil den, weil den am Ohr am Ohr der Mächtigen,
die Leute hängen und sagen, wenn wir aber jetzt hier sichere Kommunikation machen, ne, wenn stell dir mal vor, wir könnten die Handys nicht mehr abhören, dann haben wir hier Rückzug fliegt uns das Land um die Ohren, dann können wir kein W-Rock mehr machen, dann wissen wir gar nicht mehr, wo der Krisenherd ist oder was, ne? Und als nächstes äh fliegen uns hier die Kofferbomben um die Ohren
also ich bin da.
Nach wie vor bei diesem alten, abgedroschenen Spruch äh wie war das? Also den die Amerikaner haben, die Outlaw Guns, was stimmt, ja?
Ähm und ähm ähm Phil Zimmermann hat den ja dann auch mal umgeändert ungefähr so if,
Privacy oder Cryptography ist out lordlast have privacy. Ja, was natürlich auch wieder äh das Folie ist.
Ich meine, für diejenigen, die sich nicht an die Regeln halten, kannst du die eh nicht bestimmen.
Und deswegen ist es auch völlig ähm gleich ähm ob wenn man jetzt den den Status quo anhebt und eben den ja dafür sorgt, dass es eine vernünftige.
Annehmbar sichere Kommunikation gibt und nicht gleichzeitig die ganze Zeit nur daran arbeitet, die Kommunikationsmethoden, die der, die der, die der Mehrheit Mehrheit der Bevölkerung zur Verfügung stehen, zu unterwandern und kaputt auf den Markt zu bringen.
Ja, ist jetzt auch wieder ein Thema, wie gesagt, wo ich jetzt ähm,
Insgesamt ein gedanklichen Fokus drauf habe. Deswegen das wahrscheinlich auch überbewerte. Aber das wäre ähm.
Sicherlich einer der politischen Schritte, die ich jetzt in die Wege leiten würde.
Neben anderen, die ich ja dann auch schon an entsprechenden Stellen gefordert habe.
Na gut, ich meine, das.
Geheimdienste auch nicht auflösen. Das ist richtig.
Dass wir jetzt sozusagen die eigentliche Frage besen. Na ja.
Nee, die brauche ich ja dann, um irgendwie Kompromat zu sammeln über meine.
Und über die ganzen über die ganzen Typen mit den gezückten Messern hinter meinem Rücken.
Auch, sagen wir mal, schon mal, macht schon mal korrektes Wahlplakat, ne?
Ohne Änderung. Weil das doch genau das, was jeder will. Ah ja, genau, wir brauchen mal Wandel und so, aber das weiß ich jetzt nicht so viel ändern, weil eigentlich ist ja alles ganz geil. Ne, da.
Aber mehr brutto vom Netto. Äh netto vom Boto, oder?
Genau. Und wer Schoko ins Cornetto. Ähm ja, insofern würde ich sagen, äh liebe Hörer und Hörerinnen, wählt LNP.
Ah, Linus neue Partei. Oh, da wird alles gut.
Also meine Stimme hasse.
Da bin ich ja froh.
Nach der Aufnahme sage ich dir dann auch, was du dann für mich tun kannst.
Haben wir's?
Ich würde sagen, damit äh können wir uns verabschieden. Ins Sommerloch.
Ja, ab und zu mal ein Loch, aber nicht in die Sommerpause. Wir werden in den nächsten Wochen versuchen
dranzubleiben und haben so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass nicht zu viel passiert ist, weil das dann auch irgendwie moderat hinbekommen, weil wir irgendwie noch auf absehbare Zeit nicht immer in derselben Stadt sein werden, zumindest nicht, wenn wir äh Aufnahmen machen, aber ihr merkt ja schon, das geht ja auch so ganz gut.
Linus. Haben wir's, ne? Dann sagen wir tschüss, bis bald.
Tim, tschüss.